bonjour béatrice cormier bonjour
l'artiste de l'académie de martinique
merci d'être avec nous vous avez entendu
les informations madame fournier matthew
qui a semé la désolation haïti en
république dominicaine une dizaine de
morts officiellement pour leurs bateaux
qui se dirigent vers les états unis mais
auparavant
madame la rectrice alors qu'ils
n'étaient que tempête matthew a quand
même va citer les autorités
martiniquaise à prendre certaines
mesures notamment l'arrêt des côtes où
s'était bien passé la semaine dernière
alors nous avons choisi oui en effet
avec un accord avec le préfet de fermer
les établissements le mar le mercredi et
le jeudi
en appliquant ce qui s'appelle le
principe de précaution comme on savait
que la tempête à l'être pouvait évoluer
mais sans certitude de sa force
nous avons préféré prévenir que de
d'exposer nos élèves aux dangers de la
tempête vous avez certainement entendu
albéric marcellin c'est le président de
l'université populaire connu pour ses
messages concernant la préparation de la
prévention des risques majeurs pour
notre île la martinique est exposé son
nous suffisamment préparés notamment au
niveau des des écoles concernant le
risque sismique le risque d'une amie
l'évacuation dans le calme à face à à
des situations de danger
peut-on vraiment être préparé
suffisamment préparés comme vous le
dites
en tout cas pour ce qui concerne
l'éducation nationale nous faisons trois
à cinq exercices par an c'est assez
c'est assez
ce n'est jamais assez ce n'est jamais
assez face à une crise mais en tous cas
nous préparons nos cadres nos personnels
enseignants nos élèves aux exercices
d'évacuation ou de confinement et cette
année va s'ajouter l'exercice attentats
intrusions et nous sommes déjà prêts
pour cent alors la semaine prochaine
c'est donc demain il y aura un exercice
cadre qui va nous permettre de vérifier
si toutes les communications
fonctionnent entre les établissements
les forces de l'ordre et la semaine
prochaine le 14 octobre il y aura des
exercices grandeur nature dans des
établissements
un mois peu mois déjà que les cours ont
repris madame cormier quel bilan pour
cette première rentrée pour vous
rappelle que vous êtes arrivé en fin de
saison dernière fin de saison scolaire
vous êtes satisfaite des conditions de
cette rentrée 2016 2017
je suis globalement satisfaites des de
elle s'est passée dans le calme ce qui
ne veut pas dire que nous n'avons pas eu
quelques difficultés qui sont liées à
l'affectation de dernière minute
d'enseignants parce que certains sont
malades et donc il nous faut supplée de
façon à ce que tous les élèves et des
enseignants bien sûr que nous attendions
tous la rentrée au lycée schoelcher et
se trouvera est écrasé par ce dossier
éminemment politique oui c'était c'était
une rentrée attendue
on avait entendu beaucoup de choses sur
j'allais dire une catastrophe annoncée
ainsi je veux prendre que vous avez mais
perçu cela le fait de d'entamer cette
première rentrée avec un dossier
éminemment politique
comment vous vous l'avez vécu
personnellement écoutez moi ça mais je
dirais aujourd'hui que ça m'a appris
beaucoup
voilà mais ce que j'ai perçu
personnellement c'est que mon rôle j'ai
été celui du recteur c'est à dire de
faire en sorte que les élèves et les
enseignants puissent être dans un
établissement même recomposée même
relocalisé à la rentrée et que nous
puissions assurer notre mission de
service public et tant pis pour le bois
politique déjà entendu le roa politique
comme tout le monde mais moi je suis
recteur de l'académie avec la
responsabilité des élèves et des
personnels enseignants tout s'est bien
passé pour le lycée schoelcher nacro
également d'une autre cité scolaire
celle de joseph lagausie hier à sainte
marie où là aussi certains certains
bruits certaines rumeurs ont d'ores et
déjà annoncé que la rentrée 2010 est
pourrait se faire à york sur le site
actuel en effet et j'ai entendu parler
de cela alors que j'étais en réunion ii
recteur à paris ça tue ce fut donc une
surprise mais
il n'y aura pas de fermeture de la cité
scolaire des collèges et du lycée à la
rentrée 2010 élevé de risque encouru par
lui
il y à des risques encourus par les
élèves en effet des travaux vont être
menées mais il n'y a pas de prévision de
fermeture des établissements en 2017
nous sommes déjà au travail justement
pour que les choses se passent plus
calmement que pour le dossier du lycée
schoelcher
nous travaillons à long terme du
rectorat sûr ça fait du bruit le
monsieur le soir mais bien sûr que ça
fait du bruit je vais pas nier que ça
fait du bruit ou alors que je serai
atteintes de surdité
mais nous travaillons à l'interné du
rectorat sur les problèmes qui peuvent
se poser à nous pour les personnels et
les élèves et nous sommes en lien avec
la ctm pour envisager sur le long terme
comment faire au mieux donc pour
l'instant pas de déplacement de
l'association scolaire c'est ce que la
ctm m'a dit viens c'est ce qu'ont mis en
en tant que notre pays voit sa
population vieillir que ces jeunes
partent de plus en plus tôt un moment le
chiffre de 1200 scolaire en moins ce
chaque année circulait constat fait par
vos services pour cette année constat
fait aussi oui plus de 1000 élèves dans
le secondaire le premier degré
c'est-à-dire écoles élémentaires et
maternelles et cinq cent quatre élèves
en moins au collège et au lycée
alors comment vous levier tout cela est
ce que les syndicats vos partenaires le
dialogue social selon les syndicats le
comprennent entend glatt m et acceptent
l'idée de moins de postes mais pourtant
on assiste quand même à des classes
surchargées même dans le privé
côté jeux il ya dans le dialogue social
se passe bien en martinique
je comprends qu'ils ne puissent pas
accepter la baisse de postes or c'est
une réalité à laquelle va être confronté
la martinique si la démographie continue
de baisser
maintenant pour ce qui des classes
surchargées si je regarde les moyennes
nous raisonnons en moyenne bien sûr on
pourra toujours donner l'exemple
particulier mais en moyenne nous avons
une trentaine d'élèves
30 à 34 élèves dans le second degré et
une moyenne de 20 à 25 élèves dans le
premier degré ce n'est pas ce que je
peux appeler des classes surchargées si
on regarde par rapport à la main la
france métropolitaine
revenons sur le dialogue social
apparemment vos services au rectorat de
de terville semble dire que cette
rentrée s'est bien passée qu'il n'y a
pas eu de trop gros conflit en tout cas
non il n'y a pas eu de gros conflits et
les tops cormier non il n'ya pas une
méthode cormier il est simplement je
reçois les les syndicats dès qu'ils me
demandent une audience
c'est en ce moment avec une semaine
c'est ce que faisait vous pouvez tomber
je sais pas moi je j'explique aux
partenaires pourquoi je prends certaines
décisions je leur ai aussi dressé le
panorama en toute vérité de des
problèmes de l'académie et ça suffit
je ne dis pas que ça suffit mais en tout
cas j'explique pourquoi je prends
certaines décisions et je dois
reconnaître que certains d'entre eux ont
compris ce que j'explique après ils ne
sont pas forcément d'accord avec moi
mais au moins je répond à leurs
questions
la paix sociale pour l'instant c'est
tout de même mieux pour travailler
vous êtes chancelière de l'université
béatrice collin vous avez entendu ces
derniers temps que les vice présidents
des pôles guadeloupe et martinique
réclament la tenue de conseils
d'administration dans les meilleurs
délais à une situation aujourd'hui
bloquée selon eux depuis la démission de
corinne mansi casters de cette
présidence du conseil qu'est ce que vous
comptez faire là dessus qu'est ce qu'on
pouvait faire
alors les deux recteurs puisque nous
sommes de chancelier pour cette
université
nous avons nommé un administrateur
provisoire qui a pour mission d préparer
la campagne électorale et les élections
du nouveau président de la nouvelle
équipe de l'université qui prendra ses
fonctions moins de fin janvier
voilà comment se balance au niveau de
nos campagnes à leurs droits
écoutez il ya un débat comme dans toute
campagne électorale et la démocratie est
une valeur est une valeur universitaire
mais dans tout débat il peut qu'elle
parfois avoir quelques dérapages enfin
on ne le voit pas quelle université
quand même oui mais aujourd'hui on
estime que tout est bloqué aujourd'hui
que certains dossiers qui n'avancent pas
est-ce qu'il ya moyen de faire
chose en attendant l'élection du nouveau
conseil d'administration
écoutez j'ai reçu en audience des
représentants de l'université de maj
reçoit en audience avec l'administrateur
provisoire
d'autres personnels de l'université qui
ont demandé à nous rencontrer nous nous
avançons mais ce ne sont pas les
recteurs qui peuvent prendre des
décisions maintenant c'est
l'administrateur provisoire qui s'ils le
souhaitent
s'il le juge nécessaire peut convoquer
un conseil d'administration
les recteurs ne peuvent pas s'immiscer
dans la vie des établissements autonomes
nous veillons l'avant non ce n'est pas
la langue de bois c'est notre statut qui
veut ça nous veillons au contrôle de
légalité nous veillons contrôle
budgétaire mais nous ne sommes pas là
pour gérer les affaires internes des
universités par contre nous sommes là
pour être à leur écoute et les aider si
nécessaire
allons revenir dans la gestion des
écoles aux quotidiennes le périscolaire
savais que ça fait couler beaucoup
d'encre ces derniers temps est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des retours sur
cette question est ce que les choses se
passent mieux
est-ce que c'est mieux organisés est ce
que tout le monde joue le jeu alors bien
sûr que c'est mieux organisés que que
tout au début
forcément on apprend faisons mais nous
avons encore quelques municipalités qui
ne sont pas entrés dans le dispositif
pour des raisons financières mais qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire ça soit lorsqu'il se
passer vous dit on n'a pas d'argent on
ne peut rien faire ne peut pas obliger
une municipalité à entrer dans le
dispositif et que c'est le maire qui lie
c'est le maire qui est seul juge
avec ces conseils et bien sûr mais
qu'est ce qui peut se passer à ce moment
là même qui dit y a pas d'argent et puis
voilà les élèves sont livrés à eux mêmes
les parents aussi
je ne crois pas que les parents soient
livrées à elles mêmes les élèves ce
livre est elle même maman béatrice
cormier rectrice d'académie merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin dans sa
hampe l'a dit
rectrice d'académie première émission
danse aurait dit merci et bonne journée
merci